TODD KERPELMAN: Hello, and
welcome to our second official
"Google Play Games Show"--
not a game show, but
a show about
Google Play Game Services.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Important
difference.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes--
I'm Todd Kerpelman.
I'm a developer advocate here at
Google Play Game Services.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And I'm Bruno
Oliveira, and I'm a developer
programs engineer at the Google
Play Game Services.
And we are broadcasting actually
from our advanced
physics lab where we are
researching very advanced
materials like this invisible
Android doll.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes, I've
discovered I now have the
x-ray app on my phone,
which is pretty cool.
It looks through all sorts of
organic matter, which I think
will be coming out
pretty soon.
We're working on that.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So as you can
see, it's very advanced and
top secret stuff that
we have here.
And this is in no way
a green screen.
TODD KERPELMAN: Not
at all, no--
I actually did not realize until
I was in this studio
today that this is fake.
I thought this was a
real background.
So we're letting you
in on the magic.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And actually,
the real background is right
over there.
There's a camera there.
And then, there's a green screen
over here projecting a
background that's over there
over here just so that we can
have this transparent
Android doll.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's really
just for the gimmick.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: So we are here
to talk to you today about
building web games with
Play Game Services.
It's because I realized that
up until this point, we've
been talking an awful
lot about mobile.
We've been talking an awful
lot about Android
and a bit about iOS.
But web game developers,
you're people, too.
You need love.
And we are here to give you some
of that love in the form
of a demo and a presentation
that Bruno's put together.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah, talking
about advanced stuff, let's
switch to a presentation.
TODD KERPELMAN: I thought
this was just going
to be a casual talk.
But Bruno prepared slides.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: 12 slides.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
I'm impressed.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So anyway, let's
talk about building web
games using the Google
Play Game Services.
We're going to give just a very
quick overview of how to
set up your game, because we're
not going to go through
all the steps.
Because we wouldn't have time.
But let's just give a quick
overview of the steps.
So yes, we do have a web API for
Google Play Game Services.
And if you go to
developers.googl
e.com/games/services and look
at the left side navigation
menu, you're going to
find a whole section
there about web games.
So you're going to find both the
client side set up and the
client-server set up.
So there are basically these
two options for web games.
You can either do a client-only
set up where you
have, essentially, a client side
HTML and JavaScript and
no server component.
Or you can have the
client-server set up, where
your client side essentially
serves as an interface.
And then, the server is
the component that
actually makes API calls.
We're going to talk about only
the client side here, because
it's simpler.
But the server side is also
not very difficult.
The only difference is that you
have to pass your token to
the server.
And then, the server is going
to make the API calls.
But to set up the client side--
so first of all, you
should have done the
initial set up.
So you should set up
your game in the
developer console first.
Once you have that done, then
you can, from the client side,
start by loading the API.
And then, you authorize,
which means showing the
authorization dialogues
if they're needed.
And then, you can start making
the API calls as soon as you
get the callback saying
that you're signed in.
So setting up the game is
actually pretty easy.
And most of the code is pretty
much copy and paste from
boilerplate.
So just load the client.js, and
then you just write that
to initialize the Google+ API.
Once you have that done, you're
going to get a callback
saying that the APIs
are loaded.
And that's the point where
you should authenticate.
So if you just call
gapi.authorize, you can start
with this authentication
process.
If you call it with immediate
equals true, that's going to
mean that the API is not going
to show any pop-ups.
And then, if you call with
immediate equals false, that
means that pop-ups may be shown,
which means that you
should first write to
authenticate with immediate
equals true.
And then, if that succeeds,
well, that's very good.
And if that fails, you can
call again with immediate
equals false once the user
clicks a Sign In button.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'll break in
here and say, immediate equals
true generally succeeds if the
user has signed in to your
application in the past.
So this is usually for returning
players that have
already signed in.
They've already accepted.
You don't want them to have to
press a Sign In button every
time they visit your game.
And so this call essentially
tries to log them in behind
the scenes.
It's when that attempt fails
that you then say, oh, all
right, maybe we should
show a Hey, Click
Here to Sign In button.
And on clicking that Sign In
button, that's when you'd make
this call with immediate
equals false.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly, and
the reason why this is not
automatic is that most browsers
block pop-ups.
So if you try and show a pop-up
without the user having
clicked a button, that's usually
going to get blocked.
So this is why it's important
to first try to call with
immediate equals true.
And then, if that fails,
then you wait until the
user clicks a button.
And only then do you call with
immediate equals false so that
you don't get that blocking
behavior.
So next, once you have your
authenticated, you can either
use the API of a call-in
request for everything.
So you would call request.
And then, you have to pass
the parameters and so on.
But there's actually a
very handy service
called Discovery Service.
And the Discovery Service means
you can actually make
the REST API calls in a much
more convenient syntax.
And to use that, you first have
to load your API using
that syntax, which is
gapi.client.load.
Then, in this case,
I'm loading the
games API version one.
And then, this is the callback
that's going to get called as
soon as that API is ready.
So when I get a call to
onApiLoaded, I know that I can
start making the calls.
And the calls look much more
convenient than what you would
see with request.
So for instance, if I want
to list the players'
achievements, all I have to do
is call gapi.client.game
s.achievements.list.
And that's going to generate
a request that I can then
execute and then pass
my callback.
And once that callback gets
called, you're going to get
the result of that call.
So you can test, can
check for errors.
And if there's no error, then
you can do whatever you want
with that result.
In this case, I'm just
iterating through the
achievements that the user
has and then doing
something with them.
So this just illustrates just
in a few minutes pretty much
the summary of how to
use the web API.
But first, we do encourage you
to take a more careful look at
the documentation.
Because there are many
more details of this.
So with that said, let's
go on to the demo.
So this is a demo that
we've been writing
called Firewall Defense.
So this is what it kind
of looks like.
This is a screen shot.
This is the first screen.
And then, when you play, this
is the actual gameplay.
For those of you know me know
that I have a certain passion
for video games with
very big pixels.
So this is one example
of such game.
The source code for this sample
is available on GitHub.
But I'm running this
source code on my
private App Engine instance.
So this is what you're
seeing here.
So this is the game, right?
So I have this initial screen
where I show the top three
scores in the leader boards.
I have my achievements screen.
I'm actually already signed
in, so I don't
need to click here.
But for somebody playing the
game for the first time, they
would have to click Sign In.
Then, I have the achievements
over here.
So I'm showing green the
achievements that I have, and
then in grey the ones
that I don't have.
So as you can see, I've been
playing this a lot.
But I haven't really gotten a
very good score yet, unlike
some people in the
leader boards.
And then, I have the high score
screen, which shows my
social leader boards, so the
high scores from my friends.
And then, it also
shows the public
high scores from everybody.
So as you can see, I'm I think
in eighth place-- no, seventh
place-- in the list.
No, actually, that's eight.
There are 10.
So I'm reduced to eighth
place on my own game.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's
OK, I'm not even on
that top 10 list anymore.
But I am on your social
list, so that's good.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly, so
you are at 4,058 points.
So let's show the
actual gameplay.
Hopefully, the sound's going
to come out, right?
Let's see--
all right, so this is
where I try to beat
everyone's high score.
So you have these enemies
that you can shoot.
And then, they disappear.
Then, of course, one of the
challenges of the game is that
there are not only these
enemies, but also
these allied packets.
And if you shoot them, they
become missiles that are going
to try and destroy
your firewall.
Once you run out of firewall,
you lose the game, and that's
your score.
I just scored 500 points.
And of course, if that score
had been bigger, I would
appear in the--
my place in the leader
boards would change.
But my score was not that big.
But I'll try harder later.
TODD KERPELMAN: Sounds good.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah, so that's
pretty much the demo.
TODD KERPELMAN: Cool, so let's
bring up a few things that
people might be asking after
seeing this demo.
The first is, we notice that we
were able to see a list of
achievements and a list of high
scores now on Android,
iOS devices, and
their widgets.
Wait a minute--
I've been informing I need
to adjustment my mic.
How's that?
OK, I'm getting a thumbs up.
So on Android, iOS, we had
widgets to display
achievements and high scores.
Did you have widgets that you
were able to use here?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: No, if you're
doing a web game, since every
web game is pretty much
different, there are no
ready-to-use widgets.
But it turns out that the
API is actually pretty
straightforward to do that.
All they have to do is call the
load APIs, and then you
get a callback whenever you
have the data loaded.
So that's pretty much what I'm
doing here in achievements and
the leader boards.
I just make a call
to the load API.
And then, when I get the
callback, I have the data.
And then, with the data,
I just format my own
HTML with that data.
TODD KERPELMAN: So getting
the data should be pretty
straightforward.
Most of the work the developer's
going to need to
do is any CSS magic that they
want to, say, make an
achievement look nice versus
an achievement they haven't
earned, or that sort of thing?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly, so
making achievements look nice
is not in the scope
of the sample.
As you can see, they look pretty
disastrously ugly.
So what I'm doing here is,
I'm just showing the--
this is actually one of the
things I really like about
video games, is that I can use
it as an excuse to have very
poor graphics.
TODD KERPELMAN: That is true.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So this is just
the-- and I'm actually
showing the icon for
each achievement.
So when you're setting up
achievements on the developer
console, you have the chance
to upload an icon for each
achievement. and that's the
one that I'm showing.
The fact that it's always the
same is just because of my
complete lack of artistic
ability.
And I'm just using the same icon
for every achievement.
But if you had different icons
for different achievements,
you would be seeing them here.
TODD KERPELMAN: Cool, I'm also
going to ask about--
now, I know that during your
presentation, we talked about
calling gapi.authorize
to sign the user in.
But I know that for this
particular sample application,
you're using the Google+ Sign
In button, is that correct?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: That's correct,
so if I sign out--
and hopefully nothing
will go out if I do.
There we go, so I'm using the
built-in Google+ Google Sign
In button, which means
that this actually
saves me a lot of code.
Because instead of having to
write gapi.authorize and all
that, all I have to do is just
place the Sign In button and
set the properties.
TODD KERPELMAN: Right, the Sign
In button's like three
lines of HTML, essentially, that
you're putting in that
kind of does all the
work for you.
The main drawback, and the
reason, I think, we're showing
you both ways of signing the
user in, is that this Sign In
button has to appear within
a SPAN or within a DIV.
And, say, for an HTML5 game like
this, it's not a problem.
But if you were, for example,
creating a Flash game or Unity
game or something where it would
be harder to put a SPAN
on top of your game, and it
would need to be outside the
frame of the game where people
might miss it or something
like that, you would probably
want to go with the more
closer to the metal JavaScript
gapi.authorize call.
So both methods work
if you're able to
use the Sign In button.
That is the preferred way.
It also does a couple of extra
things behind the scenes.
I think it makes loading the
+1 button faster and some
other stuff like that.
So I know that on behalf of the
Google+ team, they would
prefer that you use
this if possible.
If however, your game engine
simply can't render a DIV on
top of it, or it has problems,
then go with the
gapi.authorize call.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah,
definitely, and the other item
to look out for, which was
actually a bug in the initial
version of this game, is that
if the user doesn't sign in,
you have to be careful never to
try and make any API calls
when the user's not signed in.
So notice that I'm not signed
in, but I can still play.
Of course, none of my high
scores are going to be
recorded, and I'm not going
to be able to unlock any
achievements, because
I'm not signed in.
But this doesn't mean
that I can't play.
So the recommendation is,
make sign-in optional.
So users can sign
in if they want.
And if they don't, you should
provide pretty much the same
gaming experience minus the
achievements and leader boards
and so on and so forth.
So I can still play.
It's still going to
give me a score.
But of course, none of that's
going to get uploaded.
And if I click the Achievements
button, I'm going
to have this beautiful alert
dialogue saying that, please
sign in with Google to
see achievements.
Of course, in a production
application, you
shouldn't use alerts.
But you should just integrate
that into
your game's user interface.
Even better would be to
disable the buttons.
If only I knew what the HTML
code for grey was.
TODD KERPELMAN: So when you
tried to call Uploading
Achievements before when
the user wasn't
signed in, what happened?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: What happens?
You get JavaScript errors.
So depending on the case, you
might actually survive it.
And other browsers just
stop because of that.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK,
good to know.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah, it's
always good practice to check
if you're signed in before
trying to do any API calls.
TODD KERPELMAN: And I think we
should probably point out--
this is one of four different
sample applications that are
available to you as web
developers that will all be
linked to from our
downloads page.
So this one, Firewall Defense,
is the one that actually looks
and plays like a game.
And you can kind of see
the potential, and
it's actually fun.
We also have a pure JavaScript
version of the
Type a Number Challenge.
This is our fantastic sample
game where you can enter a
number and that's your score.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's
definitely our most
user-friendly game.
It's like, if you want a
score, just type it.
TODD KERPELMAN: You type it.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Except when
playing in Hard mode, because
in Hard mode, you only actually
get half the score
you requested.
TODD KERPELMAN: That is true,
but that does demonstrate most
of the major calls in terms of
achievements, leader boards.
We also have the Type a Number
Ajaxy PHP version, which shows
an example of the client-server
set-up that
Bruno had alluded to earlier
in the presentation.
So if you actually want to see
what that looks like before
the OAuth guys get after us, I
want to point out the proper
way to do it is to request a
one-time code on the client
that you then pass down to the
server, which then exchanges
for a token.
You don't actually want to pass
your OAuth2 token down to
the server if you can help it.
But all of that is displayed
and working in
the PHP sample app.
Feel free to take a look at
that, and it should be pretty
easy to translate that to other
languages if you're not
using PHP on the backend.
We also have the Collect All the
Stars sample application.
And that demonstrates Cloud
Save in JavaScript.
That's probably something that
you should look at as well if
you're at all interested
in Cloud Save--
and you should be, because
it's kind of cool.
We did not do a client-server
version of that.
Because if you have a server
running, then Cloud Save
probably isn't quite
as interesting.
But do take a look at that.
And hold on, I'm being told
to adjust my mic again.
You know, I promised last
time that I would
wear a collared shirt.
And then, I forgot.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: You just have
to stay perfectly still.
TODD KERPELMAN: Right, well,
it's warm here in Mountain
View, so I went with
a t-shirt today--
forgot I was recording.
So we should also ask,
what about cheating?
So all the high scores are being
essentially generated
and set up by the client.
If I'm a JavaScript game
developer, is there anything I
can do to prevent cheating,
or what
strategies would you recommend?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Well actually,
on this sample, we don't do
much to prevent cheating at
all, because we want the
source code to be readable.
So we we're not doing anything
truly special here.
But of course, if you're doing a
production game, you want to
take every possible measure
to make sure that
people don't cheat.
And that starts with maybe
obfuscating your code and
making sure that it's not
that easy to tamper
with it, and so on.
But of course, maybe people
are going to find ways to
cheat anyway.
Maybe there's a special glitch
in your game logic that allows
people to get an infinite score
or something like that.
And what you can do, of course,
is, you can manage
that from the server side.
And if you notice that somebody
has cheated and has
an impossible score, what
you can do is call
the management APIs.
So the management APIs are also
documented in our web
documentation.
And what they allow you to do
is, you can authenticate as
the owner of the game, so this
means the user who created
that client ID.
And once you're authenticated as
the owner of the game, you
can hide a player's score.
Hiding means that player, the
cheater who has 1 million
points, they're still going
to see that they
have 1 million points.
But after you hide their score,
nobody else is going to
be able to see that they
have that score.
So they can go on and
be happy that they
have 1 million points.
But then, nobody else who plays
the game is going to see
that score anymore.
So he can be happy alone.
TODD KERPELMAN: And that's
much nicer than
deleting the score.
Because if it turns out this
was actually a fantastic
player who really did
legitimately get a million
points, you're able to
un-hide them later.
We should also point out, these
management APIs work for
mobile games as well.
So you would need to build a
little web client to make
these calls.
But if you notice, say, you're
building a mobile game, and
there are some people on the
high score list that maybe
shouldn't be at the level
they're at, you can hide those
scores as well just by building
a little web app that
would make these calls.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly--
of course, the burden is upon
you to make good judgments of
what is a plausible score
and what's not.
So what you don't want to do
is hide the score from a
player who actually legitimately
has that score.
So this is pretty
much up to you.
So you have to be very careful
to detect when cheating is
actually happening and
when it's not.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'd also
probably point out, one of the
best ways to deter cheating
is just focus
on the social scores.
If I'm cheating on a public
leader board, maybe I feel
like I'm a badass
hacker because I
hacked Google or something.
But if it's a social leader
board, and I've cheated my way
to the top, I'm just a jerk.
My friends will--
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly, social
leader boards have this
automatic control.
TODD KERPELMAN: Which is nice.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah,
which is nice.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, did
my microphone just jump?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's part
of our advanced
technology for this lab.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
awesome, we should also
probably point out that if
you're a Flash developer or a
Unity developer--
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Or an anything
else developer, basically.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes, anything
else, and you are looking to
make a web game like this, as
far as I know, on Flash,
probably the best strategy I
would recommend would be to
make external interface calls.
This is something that
ActionScript has that
essentially allows you
to make calls to
JavaScript from Flash.
And then, JavaScript also has
a way that you can find your
Flash object and make
calls into it.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah, I think
most browser-based plug-ins or
technologies have a way in which
you can communicate with
JavaScript.
And if it can do that, then
you can call the APIs from
JavaScript.
Even it's just a wrapper, you
could just write a thin
wrapper over the APIs in
JavaScript and then call it
from your own engine.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, I
really need to make a
sample Flash game.
I don't know if I still have
it installed on my machine.
I'm going to have to find out.
It's been a while.
But yeah, I think a sample might
be good for the flash
developers out there.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah, and if
you're using anything else
that's not web, the good thing
about it being a REST API is
that pretty much everyone
can use it.
As long as your language
platform or whatever has a way
to communicate with the
interwebs, you can
make REST API calls.
TODD KERPELMAN: So what
if I'm making a
downloadable EXE game?
Can I still do it?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Absolutely.
TODD KERPELMAN: How?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Well, you have
to go through the OAuth flow
for downloading applications,
which is not as fun
as the one for web.
Because you might have to pop
up a browser where the user
has to log in and authorize
your token.
But then, users are pretty
much used to that on
downloaded applications, so it
shouldn't be anything new.
TODD KERPELMAN: So would I be
able to display a browser
window within my game, or would
I be essentially tabbing
out to my browser, having the
user go through clicking OK,
and then going back
into the game?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's pretty much
I think up to every game,
but the preferred flow is if you
launch the actual browser.
Because it certainly works with
an embedded browser, but
the user's going to feel much
more comfortable if you pop up
an actual browser.
Because the whole point of OAuth
is that users feel very
comfortable typing their
password whenever they know
that they're actually talking to
the owner of that password.
So they should be able to look
at that URL bar and know that
they're typing their Google
password into a Google server.
So that's the whole point of
OAuth, so definitely prefer
using an actual browser
in that case.
And then, from that point on,
once you're over that
authentication part, it's
pretty much very easy.
Because then, you have the
token, and you can make REST
API calls using that token until
it expires, at which
point you have to renew it.
But then, it's pretty much
straightforward.
TODD KERPELMAN: Cool, well
all right, I think--
do we have anything else we were
going to talk about for
this session?
That's about it.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: I guess
that's about it.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
well, if you are a web
developer, we're hoping that you
found some of this useful.
Be sure to check out Firewall
Defense, which is now posted
on our GitHub page along with
all the other fantastic
JavaScript sample apps.
And start adding some
achievements to your games,
because they're always fun.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yep, and
remember, don't tell anybody
about the invisible Android
technology.
That's very confidential.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
it's still beta.
We're looking for
our last intern.
We haven't found him yet.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yep, all right,
so thank you very much,
and see you next time.